hello everybody and welcome to another
video today I'm going to show you how to
do this recipe box with angularjs using
code pan and free code camp the things
that you can do is to edit and delete or
SP and of course
Antoine it can find the user stories in
three code cup and the code will be
available in the description box of Li
the link both to make open and my github
account for this project I also in
sprite from another one like I found in
github that I will also share in the
description box and these are the user
stories that our project is doing so
I've already said loud my good but I
can't I'm using a CSS and amusing and
mix with bootstrap and materialize and
then in JavaScript I'm also using the
bootstrap Aguilar jeaious of course and
take URI for the accordion part alright
save and close and I think it's we're
ready to start this beautiful recipe box
I'm going to start with the HTML so
first of all you'll need an NG up until
will name mine recipe box the ng up
directive tells angularjs that this is
the root element of the angular
application ole einar applications must
travel route elements and then of course
you Nathan the engine controller which
in this case is race with box controller
the control corrected defines the
controller so then we are going to
continue with the class named container
and in sign there we will build
everything else for gonzaga claustro and
revert this row in two parts one call
xs8
and another one will be for in the first
part we will see all the ugly recipes
and you will have the function
of editing delete and in the right panel
we will have the odd function so inside
they're all going to start typing all
the left parts you'll need a UL class
collapsible and data collapsible
accordion later in the JavaScript we
will use we will write the functionality
for these parts and of course you'll
need an NG repeat ng-repeat will earth
needs every time you have a new race
field so your mate recipe in recipe list
and they will use filter track by index
fill their formats a subset of items
from an array for attitude directives or
I can jump it's by using the pipe
character followed by a filter and then
expression is written inside double
braces so in this case I'm going to have
a recipe title and the class is going to
be collapsible heater and then on recipe
ingredients where the class will be
collapsible body and once again I would
like to mention that if you can't see
very clear everything in my code I will
leave a link in the description box so
you can find everything there alright
now we need the ng click I'm going to
write here two functions the first one
will be edit recipe dollar index and
this will be our edit button all the
functionality will be written in the
JavaScript parts and then endings
another one click which will be the
tallit recipe and the name of course
will be science
I'm taking the two errands done with the
left parts and so now we are going to
continue with the right part away we'll
have a clone of four and inside there I
will start writing all the classes first
I'm going to have the class part and the
inside face I'm going to have a current
content here I'm using the materialized
classes so you'll see later that I won't
read a lot of CSS code I'm going to have
a new recipe and then for Angie's means
addressing the addressed is also going
to be a JavaScript function the two
rights later div class input field and
I'm actually going to do this two times
because I'm going to have two fields one
will be for the name and another one
will be for the ingredients so you will
need input type equals text ngmodel new
recipe and placeholder name
and you should do the same for the
ingredients now remember that the engine
model is very important and you will
also use it in JavaScript you don't have
to use placeholder or maybe even type
but of course you need to use the engine
module the engine handle directive finds
the value of HTML controls like inputs
like to text area duplication data you
can bind the value of an input field to
a variable created in Angela now for the
CSS becomes half body and inside the box
sizing and the seamen's will be our back
rat I will also leave this image in the
description box and so I'm going to add
some properties most of them will be
Center and actually the CSS is quite
simple so you will need a background
size cover mean hate 100 pH display flex
justified content center align items
Center text online
once again Center we phone only you can
use whichever you like I sometimes use
area sometimes return I will for to wrap
but you can use whichever you like and
afterwards I'm gonna have it before and
after the property box sizing and then
it will be inherit so every property
from the HTML is going to be inherited
great
ok now let's continue with the container
and I'm going to add a background color
I've already found the background color
the title Atkins I'm going to be use I'm
going to use RGB a and the a controls
the opacity so I don't want to be a
stronger color but I want to have some
opacity so we'll be using one
3138 117 and 0.4 now I'm just rather a
speedboat armed with a budget of 20
pixels and a card with background black
water rate is 50% color white font size
1.2 and inside there I'm gonna tell
button color block and that sees but yes
that's right for the JavaScript the
courtyard and then we're going to
continue a little bit with CSS because I
think that I form code to write
something and my image is looking quite
weird
now the accordion part is very very
simple and here is where we are using
the jQuery so you'll have document ready
function and inside there collapsible
dot
collapsible and that's it all right let
me find yes that's it
you should be it should be BH because it
stands for our vertical Heights now
everything looks nice so let's continue
with the JavaScript spurt and you will
be able to see all the functionality so
I'm going to start writing for up
angular node module so angular JS
modules defined applications whereas
controllers control the application
our controller is recipe box controller
and then we have function sculpt when
you make a controller in angularjs he
passed the scope object as an argument
but adding properties to the scope
objects in the controller the view I
mean the HTML gets access to these
properties in the wheel you didn't know
to use the prefix scope we get just
research a property name in double
braces I'm going to start creating the
initial review list from the local host
scope dot saved equals local storage dot
get item and then we have the recipe box
and is now even local storage has a
value for my key grab that if not create
a new local storage item and that's how
local storage works
so is it have scope to trace policed
equals local storage target item MST
Christ rice box different non know and
then inside here we are going to create
a JSON object
jason forwards an object to json string
so Jason got first scope don't state and
you can write your own object for me it
will be a pizza with Tom and cheese
until it's great mother 1 hmm okay it
will be cake yes I like cakes and the
gradients well I don't know well the
gradients but let's say it's just
accents milk alright I think that I have
a mistake here of course here oh my god
that's so wrong
let me fix that and of course it's the
quotations it should be like this
alright okay
I was super wrong nothing everything
works fine and I think that we are able
to continue with our next fraction ology
just copy and paste the local storage so
this could probably be in a function on
its own with how many times it's called
but it just one line so I didn't bother
gonna just copy and paste it now I want
to allow the user to add your recipe so
I'm going to use function and I will
limit at recipe the same name I used in
the HTML code so have function open
brackets and then I have an if statement
so if scope Jorge new recipe different
them know and scope totes
newgrange's is different sklearn know
then scope to address paste push title
ask apply recipe and ingredients scope
new ingredients and in that way you need
to give both a title and ingredients so
if you try to give only title or all
ingredients then you won't have a new
recipe and then I'm going to continue
with the local storage and then I'm
gonna add sculptures new recipe equals
snow and the same thing goes for
ingredients and say I did this two lines
because if you don't ask them then every
time you are going to add something
you're going to have the previous value
so with the with the know everything
like us empty I'm going to continue with
that delete so we're going to allow a
user to delete erase view I'm going to
write another function with the name
deletes recipe
and again the name is from the HTML code
so inside there we want to show confirm
alarm box alert box and to any is your
confirms it cuts the recipe out of the
array and then updates the local storage
sometimes you have an if statement and
confirm this recipe is going to be too
late it scope your dress please
spoils index one and with the spies and
the score is fullest we deal it's an
action so let's continue with me edit
which will be our last function at scope
dot edit recipe equals function index so
let's say that we grab the recipe by the
index for area and then display the
recipes ingredients in front that allows
the user to change ingredients if they
hit cancel it returns an animal response
so we will check for that also we have a
variable named ingredients equal scope
to trace the list index dot ingredients
and another variable named result with
the point edit ingredients and if
resolve is different than all then
scoped address list index dot
ingredients equals result and the local
storage once again so no I think that we
already let me check if everything is
great ok let's test it we can I did you
it can add all right uh we can add
something ok we can see it very clear
well that's adds another I think
again my example sir no it's great but I
think that you can see the point so
that's it guys thank you very very much
for watching if you have any question or
any comments please leave it in the box
below and thank you for watching